One
for a rainy day rather of age in February we started south Florida just with a rather crude
through the forest now and then we heard from the songs on the peninsula. Later
a goose caught and for girl in the
water after three or four miles the road came out on to Maryland Center
stretch here and there was it going are good don't care if you have some
orange flowers bloom aside the road. Suddenly the rain came down in torrents.
And then the roof of our car again to wreak we're sorry that we hadn't fixed
it before leaving home. There are playing and plans and involves so many
details that we hadn't thought of our clothes or had observed so
much dampness that we felt cold so we hurried into the next village.
Mary I rather think your Baptist nephews more shooting going to marry the nice girls I'm going to
be used to work in his
office the wagon used to carry the saddle in her she's up
the mountain wasn't my work won't last much longer.
They had a heated debate on American income
tax the girl is usually coming out when his horse
cart
inserts can pile of long
into him in the fine art he shouted himself
for the naked dirty of his reasoning processes
basic judgment is what you'd expect of a coupon clipper
the idea of such warmth in February.
We had a fine time in his house last night but his poor wife was worried whether she should
serve oysters in such a hot weather.
I asked how much how he expected just don't you to solve any problem.
The news maybe fall where the facts are so uncertain he burial
himself with the word old he cursed.
You know him right.
Where
are we in junior the recording
sitting in a choir.
And I know.